what does the portfolio of a creative
director look like and what skills are
needed to become one
creative professionals aren't amazing
right out of the box and like
anything you want to be good at you have
to continually develop your skills
do good work and be ready for when
opportunity strikes in this video i
interview creative director and motion
designer tom crait
to hear his story of going from intern
to creative director
we'll review his portfolio work
throughout the years and break down the
skills he developed in his career
to be working with dream clients like
nike jaguar
and microsoft before i begin i want to
thank envato elements for sponsoring
this
video now let's get into it
[Music]
so tom great to have you back on the
show i'm glad we can do a second round
of this and
see more of the work is the the first
time we were looking at your stuff you
gave us a good insight into
your process and and how you come up
with the ideas
relative to these big projects that
you're working on at different studios
with different teams
so today uh i'm really excited to see
more of that like what is what does that
end product look like and then what are
more of the steps
that it takes to get there cool yeah
thanks for having me it's uh it's a
pleasure
so this is 2006. so i just sort of cast
my mind back for some context i
graduated university in
2003 did a graphic design degree and
so i i sort of was starting to to sort
of get into after effects and animation
and it also done quite a bit of editing
and photography and stuff so that was
kind of more of the focus
before getting into motion design was
was editing and filming stuff that was
kind of like my gateway into motion
design
and motion design wasn't really even a
thing at that time at least not that i
really knew of so i was kind of like
leaving university
kind of blind and it was probably about
a year before i actually got a job in
motion design so this is
basically the work that i did during
that period i guess and then a little
bit of
personal work that i did sort of
afterwards seeing the work is very cool
it's very reminiscent of the time it
definitely is quite nostalgic definitely
brings me back to the work of things
that you would see on comedy central on
mtv and it's just like seeing motion
graphics
for some of the first times like that
was a very exciting time especially for
me
seeing that style of work because it was
designed
in movement it was designed in motion
and i know motion design had been
uh around for a while to that point but
to this level where you have all this
beautiful different aesthetics coming
into uh
into this vernacular on tv that you
would see
uh it was it was an exciting time and
it's cool to see your
uh your work from back then yeah this
it's funny how those kind of influences
have changed but definitely just like
watching tv and just seeing like mtv and
something saying what is this like
seeing music videos how the hell do they
do that like just getting really excited
about it so
yeah when i figured out that i could do
stuff like that with the program called
after effects i was kind of hooked so
cool take us into the to the next stint
i know you have another reel for us here
no yeah it's another blast from the past
so this is like a couple of years later
so i left that first job and i was just
kind of learning the ropes just
sort of getting comfortable with the
software for a couple of years and then
i started to like
getting in touch a little bit with my
own what do i actually want to do with
this stuff now that i have the skills so
like so
you can see a bit of experimentation
here again it's still all 2d
it's still all after effects stuff with
a little bit of stop motion mixed in
and i didn't learn 3d until a couple of
years after this
so yeah still in in beautiful hd
but it's a good point actually i think
that idea that because things were so
low resolution could get away with a lot
but i think the sort of
advantages of that was that you'd be
more focused on
on the sort of broader strokes of things
whereas sometimes now i think it's
really easy to get sucked into the
details you know you can spend hours or
days
just fine-tuning these little things and
and when it's not
actually having that big an impact on
the you know the piece as a whole so
that's something i always encourage my
students to try and take a step back as
often as possible just to see
you know what what's the actual outcome
here like what's the story we're telling
what's the goal
before you know it's fine to get in the
details but but make sure that you're
also getting the big picture in
at the same time so this is fast
forwarding quite a ways now so after
that
i left the uk which is where i'm from
originally moved to denmark
and started working at a motion design
studio called frame in copenhagen
and stayed there for seven years and
then
this is the reel that i made sort of
just after i
left frame was when i was kind of
starting out on my freelance career
most of it is stuff that was done with
this in the studio so it's sort of
a combination of work uh but it's mainly
the stuff i've selected is mainly
the parts that i was most involved with
particularly animation-wise which was
always my
sort of specialism that's definitely a
big jump
yeah so you can definitely see you can
see a bit of a
leap there uh but that was 10 years
right so
uh it's quite a lot of a lot of learning
and and experience going
into that period so you know it's it's
worth pointing out that like when you
see
work that comes out of studios and stuff
like that that it's a combination of a
bunch of people's work and all those
people have their own sort of strengths
and
and specialisms even even though a lot
of us are generalists
we'll all have certain things that we're
good at and maybe not so good at
um so for people that are starting out
and feeling super overwhelmed about
you know i i can't do everything like i
want to be good at this and that and the
other thing
just take it one thing at a time you
know and follow the stuff that you're
really
interested in the stuff that gets you
excited and that will
get you places you know you don't have
to do it all you just have to
sort of have a passion and and learn the
craft of whatever it is that
expresses that passion that's that's my
sort of perspective on it anyway yeah no
i think that's a great perspective and
i'm glad you shared
these reels with us because because you
can see from the beginning
your specialty was 2d animation in after
effects
and then in your next jump you start to
learn a little bit of 3d but you were
focused on stop-motion which was very
evident so it was a different
uh a craft that you started diving deep
on and then
10 years later working with different
people in different studios
you really learned 3d and
but you said all of those skill sets
stack up all of those skill sets
build on top of each other and none of
it was done alone and being in an
environment
where you are learning where you're not
the smartest person in the room or that
not the most talented but rather
with a mix of people that all bring
different things to the table
i think those are the most nurturing
types of environments that you could be
in and i think it might have been
nick from grayscale gorilla who might
have mentioned on one of his
old videos way back in maybe 2008 or
2010
but he said something like that he said
if you're the smartest person in the
room
it's probably time to leave so really
great to see this transition and thanks
for
for sharing this so we could see that it
takes
many many years to develop your skill
and to keep getting better and to add to
that and when i did leave it wasn't
necessarily that i'd you know run out of
things to learn it was just kind of a
time
for me to to sort of take a different
step in my career
um but yeah 100 about just
surrounding yourself with people that
have uh that are just better than you
in in different ways and and just
learning from that and
being open to that like just absorbing
all of that knowledge
as much as possible you've just seen a
few of tom's reels throughout the years
and can see how much he's grown over a
decade
one crucial skill that helped him become
a creative director
was the ability to generate and present
ideas to clients
we all know that there's an art
presenting your work and it could be the
difference between
winning a pitch or losing one so it's
important to have a good process
and a beautiful presentation to win them
over that's why i'm proud to have envato
elements sponsor
this video envato element is a
subscription service that helps you get
your creative projects done with over 2
million
assets that include visual mock-ups
video templates
and even presentation templates that
could help you on your next
client project the best part about an
envato element subscription
is that you have unlimited downloads
we've used envato for years and it's
always nice to have it
as a resource to use on design and video
projects
right now you can save 70 off your first
month
by using our link in the description
below clicking on that link
is one of the easiest ways to support us
here at the future and helps us make
more videos like this thank you for your
continued support
now let's get back into our interview
with tom crait
in this next section of the video we'll
take a look at a few specific pieces
from tom's career
and why they were so pivotal to his
development
i'd like to show uh this one roxilla i
love to show it to students and stuff
like that because
to me it's like in a way i think it's
the best thing i've ever done it's the
best piece of motion design i've ever
done even though it's
you know i did a long time ago and i
didn't have the skills that i have now
but there's a certain maybe like an
innocence about it
it was a personal project there was no
there was no real goal
in in mind uh it was more just to
explore the skills that i learned and
just to have fun with it and just
do something a little bit different i
always kind of look back on it
especially when i'm if i'm feeling a bit
stressed out or
like i guess we all go through those
moments sometimes where it's like
well what am i doing this for you know
when when you're somewhat sometimes the
passion is waning a little bit
and i look back on that and it's like
yeah that's why i'm doing it like it's
just
the this just the sort of just that
fun of expressing without trying to
fulfill a particular goal and it's
something that
when you do client work you don't always
get that opportunity
but i think there's always little sort
of
areas within a client project where you
can just squeeze in a little bit of
yourself you know a little bit of your
whatever it is that that kind of gets
you excited and inspired
and i think it always shows through you
know like whenever i watch this it makes
me smile because i was like
you know kind of i was just really
enjoying making it and i think that
comes through
i was gonna say that uh i think that's
so important that
i feel like too many creative
professionals
look for all of their creative
fulfillment inside their job
and they attach all of that fulfillment
from their job and it's fantastic when
you can make that happen
right when the stars align when you're
working on the like a great
project with great people and you're
learning something and expressing
the things that you really want to
express those are
pretty rare i think i some artists
are really good at just really pushing
for that and then things line up
culturally uh trend wise uh in a
commercial sense where
all of that happens for them and that's
fantastic but it's it's
pretty rare i think from from my
perspective so i too have had many
projects over the years where
i've done things just for the pure joy
of it for learning or for expression
and it was completely outside of client
work
and you know i i've had many of those
projects just to also help me
like you said it's like there's
something locked inside of us we do need
these um
creative outlets and that doesn't always
have to be client work rather
it should be something for your own
something for yourself yeah it's super
important to sort of
tap into that passion sometimes right
because it's it's it's it's kind of like
a fuel source that keeps us going and if
you let it go
too far away then you know i think
that's when the joy can start to go out
of things a little bit
plus you know if you do put the time or
you know put yourself into something
then you're more likely i think to get
to get hired for doing that kind of work
that's another sort of
bonus i think of exploring that and and
putting the time into that so this one
i've got some process work i got a
concept work it was a logo ident for a
cinema
so it's like an ident that goes before
the movies in the cinema
so that was kind of a dream for me this
was the logo that we were gonna animate
um and so this is in danish but
there's some images sort of photoshopped
images that sort of
make up the idea of this sort of giant
structure coming out of the clouds
this is an another idea about abstract
light coming together playing with the
idea of
a projector movie projector and this one
was
using constellations of stars that all
come together to form
the logo but it was this this was the
one that they ended up
going with or maybe it was a combination
of a couple
yeah so this one is is like a planetary
sunrise so it has that sort of epic
sci-fi feel to it
that's cool yeah so for those of uh
the audience watching a lot of these
are just pulled references right it's
just like a paragraph of a description
of what the idea
is and what it could be and you're just
pulling good references whether those
are images or animations
or things that you just kind of slap
together for the sake of communicating
what happens from a to z
yeah so it's really it's it's not about
really presenting anything in a fancy
way it's just like
okay i've got an idea how can i
communicate this to somebody else so
using whatever images i can find just to
put it there put it together
and then move on to the next idea that's
the process that i still use
is sort of try and come out with as many
ideas as possible
and then even if some of them seem kind
of useless or rubbish like just just
keep putting them out there and then
come back with fresh eyes and maybe pick
out one or two that are really
maybe the best ideas or maybe put a
couple of them together
and then start developing it from there
and and also often it works that way
with with clients that you you kind of
want to get on the same page from the
beginning so before you go away and
spend
days creating storyboards and stuff like
that you want to make sure that they
they like the core of the idea and the
principles and you're covering the
the communication that they want to put
out right and i think
this is unfortunately the step that uh
many creatives are scared to share it's
like showing your underwear to the
client
right it's like the it's like i just
woke up and this is what i look like
kind of look and and sometimes this is
just left internally because i feel like
this is part of the process
for many in internally but they don't
really share this with the client then
if some of you have seen our documentary
building a brand on our other channel
you see that we definitely take baby
steps with the client
from words to images that they can react
to to stylescapes or mood boards where
we can now discuss things visually
up until before we make the very first
pixel for the project right i think
that's so important
otherwise you might spend two or three
weeks making something
only for it to get shot down because
maybe the idea is nice or maybe the form
is is nice but
you didn't start at the beginning which
is getting them to buy in
early before you invest the time and
energy and resources
to make something so it's really
important to include your clients into
the process
yeah and there's nothing worse than you
know getting your heart into a project
and then
suddenly getting it cut down because
it's not the right direction for what
they want
and then and then the upshot of that
also is then you have less time to
actually execute
the final product so so the quality
overall
is also going to go down so tom just
channeling our audience because i'm
pretty sure they might ask
um with something like this how would
you present
a collection of an idea of ideas to your
client like
what how would you frame it how would
you like
how do you have that conversation so
that you can present rough ideas to a
client you know in this particular case
uh you know i'd maybe just try and set
the scene you know we start in a black
space so we're not quite sure where we
are
and then some light emerges and the
shape of a planet appears so
we're starting to get a sense of being
in you know possibly being in space
being in this vast
area and then the light appears and
starts to create like a
a crescent around the the planet which
then starts to transform into the logos
i think i'm i'm overly elaborating just
because
because we're talking about it now but
in you know in this specific case it
would have been more just like
yeah just event just the basics of it
without trying to be too
right no i don't i don't mind the
poetics so i'm very similar it's like if
if it kind of looks
kind of whatever here i do do my best
with storytelling
right and i could tell that there is
thought put into this and if i'm just
reverse engineering your presentation
here
i can already imagine what the creative
brief is like it's like okay we have to
reveal this logo in an epic way
and what does epic mean probably on a
grand scale
so it looks like all these ideas are
based off of that where you have
something that
feels big before it reveals the logo
so with something like this i think it's
quite important that
just pulling the right images just
having a paragraph here
and then prefacing that to the client of
saying
that look here are a couple of ideas
that
i wanted to share with you these were my
initial thinking of
where we could go on this based off of
the
creative brief that we received at the
beginning so i'm going to show you a
couple of slides i'm going to show you a
couple of frames and
in each of these nothing is precious on
the screen here so anything
is is very mendable very multiple and
these are just discussion starters
and then you go into the presentation of
each of these things so i think
um having some kind of framing like that
for your client
makes it feel like oh they can speak
because they're not going to step on
your toes like oh this is this creative
geniuses work i don't want to make him
feel bad
so just giving them the opportunity to
say you could poo poo
all of these ideas you could say all of
them suck and that's okay
because i have no attachment to them but
i think these are our ways that we could
take the direction of this project and i
just want to have
a conversation with you i think bringing
it down like that making it simple and
more comfortable for the client
to interact and engage and then also
insert their ideas insert
their thoughts behind what you've pulled
together so far
are very important in this step and also
if it's the sort of first conversation
you're having you're also setting the
tone for the relationship as well so
i think there's often a tendency to sort
of think well i'm the designer and i
know best
sort of thing but it doesn't work that
way even if it was the case
which sometimes it is but if the
relationship isn't there
at some point along the line there's
going to be a miscommunication or some
friction
and that can only be damaging for the
project ultimately if they don't get
what they want then nobody's
happy it's a really important step to
you know try and include them as much as
possible and
make them feel like they can say what
they want and collaborate so it doesn't
suddenly come as a surprise after
three or four weeks when they say oh you
know what we don't actually like this
thing
right because they didn't feel like they
could speak up at the beginning perhaps
so
right yeah i want to just end it with
this which is a
analogy that i forget if chris had told
me this or if it's just something that
i've been thinking about it's just like
if you go to a custom suit designer
right or if you're getting a wedding
dress right you go to the designer
and then they show you around like
here's a couple of things of
what we can make and then you try on
some things
they take your measurements and then
ultimately it's up to you to decide
what type of suit or wedding dress do
you want because that's for your big day
that's for your big presentation the
most important day
of your life right and projects should
be treated that way they are the groomer
bride
and you're making something custom for
them you have to listen to their
feedback
but present different options to help
them make a decision
and then once they make a decision
whether it's something that you
love or not you have to go with it and
you have to just help them achieve
their goal and make their day special
yeah and it's it's very
it's very tempting to get like attached
to our work you know especially when we
put a lot of
time and and effort into something you
know at the end of the day
it's still just work right you're going
to do plenty of more of that in the
future and you have plenty of
opportunities to sort of
use some of the ideas that maybe you
didn't get a chance to do this time
but generally speaking it's just a lot
more comfortable for everyone a lot more
fun
if you know that's it's a collaborative
thing and not like a
you know a sort of conflict so there's a
bunch more ideas here
and they're all kind of based on i guess
just extracting
what are the sort of elements that
suggest cinema or what are the things
that kind of
the positive qualities that you that
kind of get you into that
mood of like i'm excited to watch a
movie so a lot of it's playing with
these ideas of light and sort of
epicness
um so this one is playing with the the
bokeh of
you know just the the effect of camera
lens blur
that sort of analog effect and forming
the logo
and this one is is shadows so like
shadows coming in and forming the
the silhouette of the logo this one is a
backlight so
that idea of this sort of old-school
movie projector where you have a smoky
room and it's a very
evocative image of the cinema so like
presenting the logo in that way
so that's a bunch of the the concepts
and then just to show you how it ended
up
we we worked on this um five or six
years ago now i think
and then i actually saw it for the first
time and when i was at the cinema like a
couple of months ago and it was like
it was like a dream come true in a way
it was almost one of the things i got
into motion design for was like
i've seen some of my stuff on tv but
seeing it on the movie screen was just
like that was that was something else
yeah
i love that it looks like definitely i
could see
how this idea came to fruition based off
of
a lot of the different elements from the
different ideas right
i think you noted that it was probably
from that crescent moon
or crescent light idea but i can see the
backlight
thing coming through i could see the the
bokeh elements coming through
and that grand movement of pulling back
or pulling out
so it's i'm sure i know it's it's many
years later but it's kind of an
amalgamation of
all those different things right it's a
conversation that you have and then it
eventually becomes something like this
after many iterations
that's it yeah yeah exactly it's
conversation where it's very rarely that
first idea is what ends up being
what comes out um and it's often just a
yeah like you say like combination of
all these different things so
and that's another reason why you know i
put a lot of importance on
putting time in at the beginning to just
get ideas out
and just explore as many different
possibilities as possible because
sometimes even maybe halfway through a
project or
you kind of and maybe something happens
where
there's a part of the the piece that's
not working or there's a
request that comes in and suddenly you
can go back into that toolbox and be
like oh
i had this idea that we dropped but it
might work quite well in this situation
so
um and even if it doesn't work in that
project you know maybe there's a project
after that where there's an idea so
putting that time in to create those
just spending time
exploring ideas and just throwing them
out there
is always time well spent as far as i'm
concerned that's right you never
waste an idea because i actually have
pretty much all of my director
treatments and
the director treatments that we made at
the studio and explored
for at least a decade so sometimes i
will tap into that well
where i know i had explored an idea back
in 2010
and then there's a new project that came
up was like oh you know what i'm
connecting the dots from way back then
and i know there was a good reference
and then i'll go search for it and
sometimes it's like yes this is the
thing i already did this and i'll
just drop that idea in there and just
kind of retweet it so it's
appropriate and sometimes it's
completely not sometimes i imagine it
better than
it actually was but that actually puts
me on a path it's like well
if this is what i was thinking and it
wasn't quite that what is the modern
version of that or what's an updated
version of this so
i don't think ideas go to waste when you
exercise that or you're saying
here's a dot and here's a dot and here's
how they can come together because you
start making new things
and even if they're little nuggets right
now in the future those things can build
up and be something grand
totally right if we study uh uh some
directors like michelle gandry
right like he's made a lot of fun little
short films and experiments over the
years
and if you look at his early work he's
already explored and shown the ideas
that you saw in his big
box office films and it's like those
were little experiments those were
little nuggets
and then they became something grand and
big something that became a big
expression
on screen later so ideas don't go to
waste and just because you do it once
doesn't mean you can't do it again
totally yeah and it also goes back to
that point you're saying about you know
exploring your own
ideas like doing your own personal
projects if you can because that stuff
is also
it's never wasted like this whatever
you're learning in that process or some
of those ideas you can then channel into
uh some of the professional work and
sometimes it's like
sometimes it's really nice to revisit an
idea because you get a chance to kind of
do it over right because there's always
something you could do better so
when you get a chance to like oh i could
do i would love to do that idea and put
it in this context instead of that
context and then you have all that
learning from the first time that you
can
you know so it's it's not the same thing
it's like a sort of new and improved or
like iterated version of it
well i guess this one would be a this
one i would consider probably
perhaps the biggest leap in a sense this
was so
i was working at frame and we
collaborated with with tendril which is
a studio in
in um and it was uh so it was a big kind
of prestige project for a nike shoe so
that's that's kind of like one of the
you know i guess one of my dreams as a
as a young motion designer was to do
work on one of those kind of shoe
commercials um
so and and plus i got the chance to to
direct or i co-directed it with
chris barry who's the creator director
at tendril
um and it was so in many ways it was a
big step up for me it was a big step up
in terms of scale of client and also
sort of being responsible for um the
the concept and stuff like that so it
was it was a great opportunity to learn
from chris
and and um see how he did things as well
and i really learned a lot from him
uh because he you know he's been
directing projects for a lot longer than
i had
uh over with ten over at tendril so and
and just the way that they dealt with
the whole process
the workflow working with a big client
and having you know a lot of freelancers
also involved in the project
i have to ask because i know the
audience is probably wondering this
how did you get that opportunity to
direct this because
prior to this you shared some personal
uh
things that you did and then obviously
working as part of a team
i'm guessing under some uh director with
a client and then now you're at this
point in 2015
with nike your dream job and you're
co-directing this with
uh the team over at tendril and a bunch
of talented people in
house how did you get to this point
where
now you are at the helm here and getting
to direct and kind of
decide where does this go i actually
think
that i got the chance to do that because
anders who's the
the the the uh the chief creative
director of frame i think he was
um he couldn't do it for some reason i'm
not quite sure i don't
quite remember but i think it could have
been that case that maybe i wasn't the
first choice but i just got lucky
uh and you know sometimes you just have
to take those opportunities
um and but i know that if i you know if
it hadn't been that one it would have
come eventually you know it was there
was a gradual progression of
of just developing my skills and and i i
always i think from fairly early on i i
had a
desire to sort of direct because i i
think i always had a leaning towards the
conceptual side of things
um and i think going all the way back to
you know
filming and editing stuff i think that
still
was kind of informing the way i work
that i tend to think of things in terms
of
a full story and a sort of story arc and
how the shots fit together more than you
know looking at specific things and also
i think because i wasn't like uh
perhaps it helped me the fact that i
wasn't the strongest designer
because as a designer you tend to focus
on more on the visuals and the specific
shots and i think because my strength
was more in in motion and editing
that that naturally has more of a you're
more thinking about
the bigger picture and how things
connect and flow together
so i think all of those things kind of
sort of helped me along that road
um and then just being given trust you
know like i still
um are really appreciative to the i've
done a lot of work with with tendril
since and that you know
they they put a lot of faith in me and
and the guys at frame as well to sort of
they didn't once they'd given me the
thing it wasn't like oh well we'll we'll
just
sort of you know give him some scraps it
was like okay you're you know you're
you're leading this thing you can
present this to the client you know i
was terrified
it was the first time i presented like a
treatment to a client
and it was nike and i was you know but
but they the fact that they backed me up
and trusted me
um went a long way as well yeah no i
think that's huge and i think this is
actually a good place to end because
we saw all of your progression um just
starting as
an animator learning things in 2d and
then exploring some
things that you wanted to learn yourself
which is stop motion and doing a passion
project there then eventually
leveling up and starting to learn 3d but
always kept those core skills along the
way
and then starting as an internet frame
in 2009 uh
you know up until the later years you
built incremental trust along the way
through the projects that you delivered
on through the ideas that you came up
with
and eventually you got a chance you got
a chance where
okay somebody has to set out this one
who's next in line
and of course the person who you feel
like
can deliver can bring something and has
been pretty consistent at that point
you give that person a shot and that was
you at that moment so
i think those are all very important
learning lessons as people
think about their career whether they're
early on or later
you're trading up and you're trading up
based off of the trust that you build
with the
clients the studios and your peers that
you work with
and the skills that you grow and
eventually develop along the way and
it's not something that just happens
instantly your journey here that we saw
this is like a 10-year thing
at least yeah way more you know it goes
all the way you know all the things that
i
you know did in school and university
and all that stuff like
fed into it i think right so i think
it's really important
for people to think about the long game
because i know how difficult it is to
see the thing that's right in front of
you and wanting
that progress that improvement right now
but it does take time
as long as you have a good attitude
about wanting to learn more
pushing yourself and still finding the
moments of fun and passion
in the things that you love 100 yeah
yeah so
i think that's a great place to end tom
thank you so much for
sharing your your work with us so tom
if people want to find more out about
you where can they go to look you up
so yeah everything's on my website
tomcreate.com
i have all my work there i also have a
blog and i also have a
an online course and you can find links
to that on the website as well
lots of stuff cooking up as well i have
a podcast on the way and some more
youtube videos so
but if you go to my website you can also
sign up for a newsletter if you want to
uh get updated on on any new stuff
that's coming out
easy love that thank you so much tom and
uh
we'll see you next time sweet thanks so
much i hope you enjoyed today's
interview with tom crait
i'm sure it gave you some insight into
how a creative director works
and how they develop their skills over
time if you liked this interview with
tom we actually did another video with
him recently
which we'll link to in the description
below if you have any questions
leave us a comment and we'll do our best
to answer it and before i go
i want to greet all of you a happy new
year
2021 is just getting started and we're
planning all kinds of content here
on the channel if you'd like to learn
something new
or see someone specific on the channel
let us know by leaving a comment below
and your suggestions will help shape
what we do here
in the coming year thanks all for
joining us i'm matthew encina
and we'll see you in the future